I'm gonna do this so today is oh sorry today yeah good today we're going to have a nice I was Sean no it's just the last time you started the last one I was gonna start this one okay we're just doing an intro so it doesn't matter to start so I'll just go let me just do it listener here is smart listen I think it's been three weeks since we've we've done this since I've seen you since I've talked to you and I have to say I've had some long drives in the last three weeks so I've gone ahead and done some quality control looking listening to our podcast I'm not great at it because I'm listening to them after
我要这样做，所以今天，噢抱歉，今天，对，好，今天我们要来一个美好的……我当时想说——肖恩，不，上一次是你开始的，上一次我本来要开始这一场的，好吧，我们只是在做一个开场，所以谁先开始都无所谓，所以我直接来吧，让我来做这个。听众朋友，听着，我觉得距离我们做这个已经过去三周了，距离我见到你、距离我和你说话已经过去三周了，我必须得说，在过去的这三周里，我有过几次很长的驾车行程，所以我顺便做了一些质量控制，听了我们的播客。我不擅长这个，因为我是等它们
they've already reached the public so I'm picking up some long hauler miles I've got some five-hour energy cases I'm trying to get through okay sure so it's really been nice listening to you fellas you're both very talented and very funny on the podcast I'd really like to be more of a part of it but so I was very excited to part of it I was very excited to see you guys today but then this morning this morning this morning a real dark cloud floated over our family here is it possible to say that is it possible for a dark cloud to then give you a gut punch is that possible sure what happened yeah well why don't you
已经公开发布之后才去听的。所以我也积累了一些长途里程，我带了好几箱“五个小时能量”饮料，正努力把它们喝完。好吧，当然，所以听你们这几个家伙聊天真的很棒，你们在播客里都很有才华而且非常搞笑。我真的很想更多地参与其中，所以我非常高兴能成为其中的一部分，我很高兴今天能见到你们，但就在今天早上，今天早上，今天早上，有一朵真正的乌云飘过了我们这里的这个家庭。有可能这么说吗？乌云有可能随后给你当胸一拳吗？这有可能吗？当然，发生了什么？好吧，为什么不
take it from here well Jason read something that I read we all read it oh god I read it I read it after you sent it to me here we go actually you know it Sean sent it that's sure I said that before I read it I don't think so Sean sent an article to Jason and me in the thread that we're in with some feigned exclamation points like yeah this is great for us and by the way I'm gonna put it out there if anybody thinks they're worthy of being in the text thread let us know and maybe we'll add you on the yeah we'll add you to the thread and Sean says congrats for us yay for us and it's a click to the
由你来接着说呢？好吧，杰森读了一些我读过的东西，我们都读了，哦天哪，我是在你发给我之后读的，我们来了。其实你知道吗，是肖恩发过来的，对，我甚至在读之前就这么说了，我不这么认为。肖恩在我们的群聊里发了一篇文章给杰森和我，带着一些假惺惺的惊叹号，比如：“哈哈，这对我们来说太棒了。”顺便说一句，我要在这里表态，如果有人觉得自己配得上加入这个微信群，让我们知道，也许我们会把你加到……对，我们会把你加到群里。肖恩说：“恭喜我们，为我们欢呼吧！”这是一个链接，指向
Hollywood Reporter smart list nominated great nominated for a bunch of podcast awards or whatever which is kind of neat because this is you know this is an embarrassment mom and pop operation yeah we're we apologize yeah the fact that we're getting any traction whatsoever let alone nominations just thank you yeah it's pretty great thank you and also it's embarrassing I think Jason's read it is kind of embarrassing so so then as you if you read further down in the story they're nominated best podcast blah blah and Sean Hayes nominated for best host okay which is the worst which the kiss of death because now it was like
《好莱坞报道》聪明榜，提名，太棒了，获得了好几项播客奖项的提名什么的。这其实挺酷的，因为你知道的，这是一个让人难堪的夫妻老婆店式的运营。是的，我们道歉。是的，我们能获得哪怕一点点关注，更不用说获得提名了，这真的非常感谢。是的，相当棒，谢谢。而且这也挺尴尬的，我觉得杰森读过之后也觉得挺尴尬的。所以然后，正如如果你继续往下读文章里的话，他们获得了最佳播客提名什么的，而肖恩·海耶斯获得了最佳主持人提名。好吧，这简直是最糟糕的，是死亡之吻，因为现在感觉就像是……
well he's not really that great well you're I don't think they're saying it out of the side of their mouth either I think you come straight out the center and here's my thing today I can't wait to see you host yeah let's see what you got Sean this is gonna be the worst experience for me yeah well the voters are now listening right because the nominations are out now they really have to decide attention to his house my questions are still gonna be like hey where are you from yeah no don't worry we know that obviously resonates with the with the jury over there the I heart media people have made a bunch of
好吧，他其实并没有那么厉害。好吧，我觉得他们也不是言不由衷，我觉得他们就是直言不讳。而我的问题是，今天我迫不及待地想看你主持了，肖恩。让我们看看你有什么本事，肖恩。这对我来说将是最糟糕的体验。是的，好吧，投票的人现在在听了，对吧？因为提名已经公布了，他们真的必须决定……注意他的主持。我的问题仍然会是：“嘿，你来自哪里呀？”是的，不用担心，我们知道这显然能引起那边评审团的共鸣，那些 iHeartMedia 的人们犯了一大堆
mistakes when Sean said when Sean said what's your favorite color I mean let's nominate that jackass yeah here we go geez I'm not gonna be able to come up for air for a while and we're thrilled for you Sean yeah we really are thrilled for everybody and I said this I said to Sean by the way I did say congrats man and he's like oh thank you and I responded I didn't mean it what are you doing I actually I responded with I didn't I didn't read the I truly didn't know I didn't read the article I just read the headline like most people sure it is true I think Sean might be the kindest man I've ever
错误。当肖恩说——当肖恩说“你最喜欢什么颜色？”时，我的意思是，提名那个笨蛋吧！哈哈，我们走着瞧。天哪，我有一段时间都喘不过气来了。我们为你感到高兴，肖恩，是的，我们真的为每个人都感到高兴。我当时这么说的，我顺便对肖恩说，我确实说了“恭喜你，老兄”，然后他说：“噢，谢谢。”而我的回复是……我不是那个意思，你在干什么？我其实回复的是……我没有……我没有读这篇文章，我真的不知道，我没有读文章，我只是像大多数人一样看了标题。当然，这是真的。我觉得肖恩可能是我见过的
out I possible no one deserves it more not around you too all right zip it up we got we've got a we've got a we've got an interesting guest today he's he's known primarily in New Zealand and in South Africa due to his success in Rugby okay Florida then came to love him when he pivoted his talents towards highlight and dog racing and then when he was in California he was attempting to be the first to successfully mend the San Andreas Fault he tried his handed acting and and while fame and fortune there has been scarce at best some call it a wipeout sure the critics have given him a few hugs so he has received a
最善良的人……可能没有人比他更配得上了。行了你们俩，闭嘴吧。我们今天迎来了一位有趣的嘉宾，他主要因其在橄榄球领域的成功而在新西兰和南非闻名，好吧。后来当他把才华转向赛狗时，佛罗里达州的人们也开始喜爱他。再后来，当他在加利福尼亚时，他曾试图成为第一个成功修复圣安德烈亚斯断层的人。他尝试过演戏，虽然那里的名利最多也只能算稀少——有人称之为惨败，当然，评论家们也给予了他几次拥抱，所以他获得了
couple of Academy Awards and seven Emmy Awards what yeah he's gotten himself a Tony nomination he turned it around he got a lifetime achievement award from AFI BAFTA gave him something the Golden Globes gave him the Cecil B. DeMille Award the Kennedy Center honored this this highlight player and Barack Obama gave him the Presidential Medal of Freedom wait so I should chin up I say chin up to this fella no idea this is the most the most highly decorated guest we've ever had I would say so yet he's famous and fortunate in our book okay please welcome the forever struggling but always diligent America's own and
几座奥斯卡奖和七座艾美奖。什么？是的，他还获得了一个托尼奖提名。他扭转了局面，获得了美国电影学会（AFI）的终身成就奖，英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）也授予了他某种荣誉，金球奖授予了他塞西尔·B·德米尔奖，肯尼迪中心向这位精彩的演员致敬，巴拉克·奥巴马还授予了他总统自由勋章。等等，所以我应该昂首挺胸吗？我对这家伙说昂首挺胸？毫无头脑，这是我们接待过的名誉最高、获奖最多的嘉宾。我会这么说，然而他在我们心中既有名望又有财富。好吧，请欢迎这位永远在挣扎但始终勤奋的、属于美利坚的、好莱坞最棒的汤姆·拉马尔·汉克斯先生！
Hollywood's best Mr. Tom Lamar Hanks yeah I know that Sean was the host of this podcast I would have bailed I said guys I'd like to but you know I don't like to work from home apparently you're working with one of the brightest hosts in the business yeah is there a name for this award is it does it named after somebody is it it's called the the aorta because it's from my heart media oh I okay that's not true but that's my pitch one of my heart-hitting nominee questions is where are you right now I don't recognize that room I'm a I'm in a tiny little cubby hole that is here in my vast compound somewhere in the
耶！我知道如果肖恩是这个播客的主持人，我早就跳船了。我说过：“伙计们，我很想去，但你知道的，我不喜欢在家办公。”显然你正在与业内最聪明的主持人之一合作。是的，这个奖有什么名字吗？它是以某人的名字命名的吗？它叫做“主 aorta 奖”，因为它是来自 iHeartMedia 的。噢，我……好吧，这不是真的，这是我的推销。我那些尖锐的提名问题之一是：“你现在在哪里？我不认识那个房间。”我在一个极小的隔间里，它就在我位于三州地区某处的庞大庄园里。
tri-state area I'm telling you dog racing really pays guys you got to look into it it's within a single days drive from Lakewood Ohio home of the Great Lake Shakespeare Festival wait you didn't is it true no no we already get a plot we already plugging a festival I mean well it's a long time ago wait did you really do dog racing no dumbass this is why you're not gonna win Jason was demonstrating his quote comedy chops yeah guys can I write or what huh we hang on I think Tom's on to something let's get into Jason's comedy you know I told I told some friends last night that I was doing this podcast and
我跟你说，赛狗真的很赚钱，伙计们，你们得了解一下。它距离莱克伍德（俄亥俄州）大湖莎士比亚戏剧节只有单程一天的车程。等等，你没有……真的吗？不，不，我们已经在宣传了吗？我们在宣传一个戏剧节吗？我是说，那是很久以前的事了。等等，你真的搞过赛狗吗？没有啊，笨蛋！这就是为什么你不会赢。杰森刚才是在展示他的所谓“喜剧才华”。是的，伙计们，我会写剧本还是怎么着，哈哈？等一下，我觉得汤姆说得有道理，让我们来深入探讨一下杰森的喜剧。你知道的，我昨晚告诉一些朋友我要做这个播客，
first of all I had to re-explain your name we were yeah I said Sean who Jason what will huh what is the name of it yeah I kept calling it helpless based on the Neil Young song so but now I realized no no no it's it's smart less we really are helpless and the question came up about you will oh which is which was this question is has he started using a different voice professionally mm-hmm that in your early days you were kind of like squeaky you sort of sounded like Jane North in those old Dennis the menace reruns and you were hilarious but then you went off and voiced Batman and it's though you're
首先，我不得不重新解释你们的名字。我们当时……我说肖恩是谁？杰森是谁？哈？这叫什么名字？是的，我一直把它叫作“无助”（Help-less），根据尼尔·杨的歌名来的。但现在我意识到，不，不，不，它是“聪明无知”（SmartLess）。我们真的是无可救药。然后问题就来了，关于你的，噢，也就是这个问题是：他现在在专业上开始使用不同的嗓音了吗？嗯？在你的早期，你的声音有点像尖叫，听起来有点像老版《丹尼斯威胁》重播里的简·诺斯，你当时滑稽极了，但后来你去给蝙蝠侠配音了，这就好像你现在走路时还在自己的声音上强加了一个自设的均衡器一样，对吧？
walking around with your own self-imposed EQ on your voice now yeah true or false will here I listen I like any good politician I can't just give you a straight true or false I will say that I constantly have a monitor in my year and I'm and I'm adjusting my levels my input levels right and so then I can I can monitor no you know what it's funny I recently you know I often watch a lot of my old stuff because I like to be entertained and he has trouble sleeping yeah no but I my voice has gotten it has but if you listen to Howard's it's because of abuse I guess are you do you still smoke well who's listening I'm
真的还是假的，威廉？听着，像任何优秀的政治家一样，我不能只给你一个简单的“真的”或“假的”。我要说的是，我的耳朵里一直塞着一个监听器，我在调整我的音量级别，我的输入音量级别，对吧？然后我就可以……我可以监听。不，你知道吗，有趣的是，我最近……你知道的，我经常看很多我以前的作品，因为我喜欢让自己开心，而且他有睡眠障碍。不，但是我的声音已经……确实变了。但如果你听霍华德的……那是因为虐待吧，我猜。你还在抽烟吗？好吧，谁在听呢？我
just learning I'm just learning we had Sean Penn on the podcast he's he's he went through a full pack of darts didn't he he did go through a pack of darts that's colloquial of her cigarette as Canadian as opposed to say coffin nail or or a nail a nail or bullet actually Tom this brings me to an actual question about the nail I noticed recently I was reading the 10th book in the in the gunter what's his name series by Phillip Kerr and I noticed your name on the back of the you gave a little blurb for the back of for the jacket of Prussian blue which I'm almost finished with oh that's a great one it's a great
只是随便了解一下，我只是在了解。我们之前请过肖恩·潘上播客，他抽光了一整包烟，对吧？他确实抽光了一整包烟。“Darts”（飞镖）是香烟的俗称，就像加拿大的叫法一样，而不是像“棺材钉”或者“钉子”、“一颗钉子”或者“子弹”。实际上，汤姆，这让我想到了一个关于“钉子”的真实问题。我最近注意到，我在读菲利普·克尔写的冈瑟——他叫什么名字来着？——系列小说的第 10 本，我注意到你的名字印在封底上，你为《普鲁士蓝》的封套写了一段推荐短评，我快读完了。噢，那是一本极好的书，那是一本极好的
one right Gunther help me Bernard Gunther Bernard Bernard Bernie Gunther series he plays a non okay be merciful on me on this okay he plays a non Nazi private investigator from 1928 Berlin through well after the war yes right it's a fabulous series by Philip Kerr the late Philip Kerr he passed away I know too early yeah and I read them all and just well I'm not a big I'm not a big like detective genre fiction writer me neither but this had that added bonus of very accurate sort of historical detail to it that that I really loved it's a tremendous historical fiction and you're absolutely right and I'm with you
书，对吧？冈瑟，帮帮我，伯纳德·冈瑟，伯纳德，伯纳德·伯尼·冈瑟系列。他扮演一个……好吧，对我仁慈一点，好吗？他扮演一个非纳粹私家侦探，故事从 1928 年的柏林一直持续到战后很长一段时间。是的，对吧？这是菲利普·克尔的一部极棒的系列小说，已故的菲利普·克尔，他去世了，我知道，太早了。我都读完了，只是……我不是一个侦探流派小说的大粉丝。我也不是，但这本书有一个额外的红利，那就是非常准确的某种历史细节，我真的很喜欢。这是一部了不起的历史小说，你完全说得对，我和你一样，
Tom and I read I read mostly non-fiction in somebody recommended they said you love all this European history I think you'd like this I'm fully it like I said I just started at the beginning of the summer and I'm on book 10 Prussian blue and but he always refers to cigarettes as nails and he gets beaten up by these Nazis and then they look down and he's spitting up blood and they say what do you want he looks up and he says kind of get a nail yeah and you know what when he smokes one he looks really cool he looks really really cool what I like about those books is it fills in the blanks of his war years because some of
汤姆，我读的大多是非虚构作品。有人推荐说，你热爱所有这些欧洲历史，我想你会喜欢这个。我完全……就像我说的，我刚在夏天开始读，现在看到第 10 本《普鲁士蓝》。但他总是把香烟称为“钉子”，然后他被这些纳粹痛打，接着他们低头看去，他吐着血，他们问：“你想要什么？”他抬起头说：“能来根钉子吗？”你知道吗？当他抽上一根时，他看起来真的很酷，看起来真的非常酷。我喜欢这些书的原因是，它们填补了他战争岁月的空白，因为其中一些
them take place well before World War two some of them take place after World War two and in the course of it you see what he went thanks guys for firing us out of the gate here at the start of the interview and our listeners love literature go Sean you're the host let's do it yeah come on by the way Sean I have my hand on my buzzer hand is right on my buzzer okay good I want to know what your fascination with with war is because your name is so synonymous I've never asked you this in my entire life why are you so passionate yeah you're the war guy the history of it's starting to highlight I think right dog racing you
故事发生在第二次世界大战之前很久，有些故事发生在第二次世界大战之后，在阅读的过程中，你会看到他经历了……谢谢你们在访谈刚开始时就把我们轰下台，我们的听众热爱文学。来吧，肖恩，你是主持人，我们开始吧。来吧，顺便说一句，肖恩，我的手放在蜂鸣器上，我的手就放在蜂鸣器上。好吧，很好，我想知道你为什么对战争如此着迷？因为你的名字与……我这辈子从来没问过你这个，为什么你这么充满激情？是的，你是战争专家，关于它的历史……开始突出了，我想，对吧？赛狗，
know first of all we do a lot of them because none of the projects have to have cell phones or laptops so that alone makes the writing of them so much easier and there's much less special effects of having to put in those screens but it I have I get this question asked to me quite often and the answer always comes down to when in those formative years of say seven through you know when you're a little kid you know every single caregiver every single adult in my life would make references to the six two words three letters each the war and they talked about it as is this great dividing line
你知道，首先，我们做了很多这样的项目，因为这些项目中没有一个需要手机或笔记本电脑，仅此一点就让剧本的创作变得容易得多，而且也不需要加入那么多特效来制作那些屏幕。但我经常被问到这个问题，而答案总是归结为：在那些形成性格的岁月里，比如说七岁到……当你还是个小孩子的时候，你知道的，我生活中的每一个照顾者、每一个成年人都曾提到过那六个字、每三个字母一组的词——“那场战争”。他们谈论它时，仿佛它是他们生活中那条巨大的分水岭：
in their lives there was before the war there was during the war and there was just after the war and they talked about it as though it's almost like well that was when the black plague was walking among us you know for for a big chunk of their lives they had no idea where they were going to be in another six months they had no idea how long the war was going to last that's that's one big aspect of it the other part of it too is is that the bad guys lost yeah at the end of the day yeah just yeah we were able to somehow unfortunately necessarily kick the stuffing out of them and when bad guys
战争前、战争期间、以及战争刚刚结束之后。他们谈论它的方式，几乎就像是……那是黑死病在我们中间游荡的时期。在他们生命中的很大一部分时间里，他们根本不知道自己再过六个月会身在何处，他们也不知道战争会持续多久。那是很大的一个方面。另一部分原因则是，坏人们最后输了。到头来，是的，就是这样。我们不知怎么地——不幸的是也是必须地——把他们打得落花流水。而当坏人们
lose something it's that what is that power of myth of is it Bill Moyers you know and you know the world was on a quest to defeat people that were undeniably evil the governments of those places and many of the many of the populace so I keep getting drawn back to that and again I will say that from a storytelling perspective our present day is just so there is no shame left anymore you know truth seems to be a a malleable viscous kind of like it's a distant memory truth it seems like and actually you know what Tom is Sean actually within the last six months I don't know if you remember we were
输掉某些东西时……那是什么？那是神话的力量吗？就像小比尔·莫耶斯说的（你知道的），世界曾踏上一场旨在击败那些无可否认是邪恶之人的征程，那些地方的政府以及许多民众。所以我一直被它吸引回来。而且我要再次说明，从讲故事的角度来看，我们当今的时代实在是……已经没有任何羞耻感可言了（你知道的）。真相似乎变成了一种可塑的、黏稠的、类似于遥远记忆的东西，真相似乎是这样的。而且实际上，你知道吗，汤姆？肖恩其实在过去六个月里……我不知道你记不记得，我们在
talking about all the movies you've done at the war moves and Tom said do you think he'll ever make a movie about tiktok and you know because something that he thinks about for Sean and Scotty there's before tiktok after tiktok well you know if I did it would only be about 45 seconds long how long how long is your average tiktok and then I won't be I can't and then I won't be able to wait for the sequel Tom I know that I know that you would you'd never compare your experience shooting save a private private Ryan to those who actually fought you know in all of that and during all that but was there ever
谈论你拍过的所有战争电影，然后汤姆说：“你觉得他会拍一部关于 TikTok 的电影吗？”你知道的，因为那是他为肖恩和斯科蒂考虑的事情。对于 TikTok 之前，TikTok 之后……好吧，你知道的，如果我拍的话，它大概也就只有 45 秒长。你的平均 TikTok 视频有多长？然后我就不能……我等不及看续集了，汤姆。我知道，我知道你永远不会把你拍摄《拯救大兵瑞恩》的经历与那些真正参战、经历这一切的人相提并论，但在拍摄过程中，有没有那么一个时刻……
a moment I'm sure I bet there was a few moments while you were shooting that where you got close to the feeling maybe of what it might have been like I mean certainly the product the result of that film took me there or as close as I I think I could get but I would imagine there were a few moments there were it just based on the quality of the production they managed to create some environments for you there and your own process of trying to get into the character and the realism of it where you you were kind of struck a bit by what these guys must have gone through well yeah but at the same it was all fake you
我确信，我敢打赌在你拍摄期间有那么几个时刻，你可能接近了那种感觉，也许能体会到那可能是什么样的。我的意思是，当然，那部电影的成品和结果把我带到了那里，或者说尽可能地带到了我所能达到的地步。但我想象在其中有几个时刻，仅仅基于制作的质量，他们设法为你创造了一些环境，加上你自己试图进入角色以及追求真实性的过程，让你在某种程度上对这些家伙必定经历过的一切感到触动。嗯，是的，但与此同时，这一切都是假的，
know sure but I mean you got to take that into account but when you were on the beach there in County Wexford in Ireland which is where we shot the Omaha Beach sequences oh so it wasn't wasn't right there well it was actually it was one of the places where they rehearsed some of it so that's one aspect how far was base camp from the beach it was way well I was gonna I was gonna incorporate that into the go so just light up another nail will take that pause we're there with 500 members of the Irish actual members of the Irish army there is landing craft everywhere and we're all storming storming the beaches and the
你知道的，当然，但我的意思是，你必须把这一点考虑在内。然而，当你身处爱尔兰韦克斯福郡的海滩时——那就是我们拍摄奥马哈海滩场景的地方。哦，所以它其实不在诺曼底？嗯，它其实不是……好吧，它其实是他们排练其中一部分内容的地点之一，所以这是其中的一个方面。大本营离海滩有多远？嗯，它是……我本来想把它加入到……所以，再点上一根烟吧，我们暂停一下。我们在那里，有来自爱尔兰军队的 500 名真正士兵，到处都是登陆艇，我们都在冲锋，冲向海滩。
special effects crew had laid out these tiny little flags on the beach where they had set up air mortars and squibs little explosive devices things to avoid yeah and they actually said you know I be carefully right because you know this is going to become this is like a projectile it'll come out at a ground very fast so if you can try to avoid where the flags are you know I think I got that then they removed all the flags and we couldn't see anything oh my god where so we were just stumbling all wondering why so there's all of that and it's dressed the way it is and when you there were always four
特效团队在海滩上放置了这些小小的旗帜，他们在那里设置了空气迫击炮和小炸药包、小型爆炸装置等需要避开的东西。他们实际上说：“你知道的，小心点，因为你知道的，这将会变成……这就像一个抛射物，会以极快的速度从地面冲出来，所以如果可以的话，尽量避开那些插旗子的对方。”你知道的，我想我记住了。然后他们把所有的旗帜都撤掉了，我们什么也看不见了！天哪，在哪儿？所以我们只是跌跌撞撞地走着，不知道为什么……所以这一切都有，而且场景布置就是那个样子。当你……
or five cameras going and once the shot began and you're wet and you're cold and you're coming up and at a corner of one eye you see a guy catch on fire and at a corner of the other eye you see a guy blown 40 feet into the air and he loses a leg in the process literally we had you know amputee stunt people oh my god then there were they were amputated before you shot amputated thank god just to clarify even though there's harnesses and there's wires and why not machine guns are going off all around you and explosions are happening like crazy and it goes on for the better part of you know two or three or four
那里总是有四五台摄像机在运转，一旦镜头开始，你身上又湿又冷，你从水里爬上来，在眼角的余光中，你看到一个人着火了；在另一只眼睛的余光中，你看到一个人被炸飞到 40 英尺的高空中，并在过程中失去了一条腿。字面意义上，我们有……你知道的，截肢特技演员。噢，天哪！然后他们……他们在你拍摄之前就已经截肢了？谢天谢地！只是为了澄清一下，尽管身上绑着威亚和钢丝，四周机枪疯狂扫射，爆炸声疯狂作响，而且这种情况持续了足足……
minutes and there was a there was a degree of sort of like odd fake and yet the same time terror that was going on yeah so we were shooting then they're all morning along I'm gonna say about on the baby the second day of shooting because the first day of shooting was spent in the boats themselves and I climbed up the steps to the bluff they had put in these wooden steps so we could get up to the base camp well that's for catering and craft services would not far as the crow flies but it was awfully high it was probably about six seven hundred feet up the bluffs and I went back and I found the other guys
两三分钟甚至四分钟，有一种莫名其妙的虚假感，但与此同时又伴随着恐惧。所以我们在那里拍摄，整个上午都在拍。我要说的是，大概是在拍摄的第二天——因为第一天拍摄全花在小艇本身上了——我顺着木阶梯爬上了峭壁，他们搭了这些木阶梯，好让我们能爬到大本营。噢，那是餐饮和后勤服务所在地，直线距离其实不算远，但它高得吓人，峭壁大概有六七百英尺高。我走回去，找到了同组的其他伙伴，
in the unit who I would be meeting when we got up to the shale which was a you know the deflate that was at the top of the beach that's where I would come across Barry Pepper and Eddie Burns and Vin Diesel and the other guys and they were still hanging around you know outside the trailers the way actors do sure and I was wet and I was sandy and I was near death from the amount of noise that had gone on and I told the guys that you guys better hold on to your hats because it's really wild down there you are not going I mean when you see a guy catch on fire out of the corner of your eyes you're cut and no one said you
就是当我们爬上页岩——也就是海滩顶部的那个平地——时我会见到的那些人。就在那里，我遇到了巴里·佩珀、埃迪·伯恩斯、范·迪塞尔和其他几个家伙，他们当时还在拖车外面闲晃，演员们总是那样，当然。而我当时又湿又沙尘仆仆，由于刚才经历的巨大噪音，我简直濒临死亡。我告诉这群家伙，你们最好抓紧帽子，因为下面真的太疯狂了，你们不会……我是说，当你看到一个人在眼角余光中着火时，你喊了“卡”，却没有人说……
know no one's prepped you no one has said there's gonna be a guy caught on fire on this side and it's it all you're it was it was an interesting kind of kind of panic you know it's interesting and this is kind of folding back to what you were saying earlier one of the reasons that what I love about that movie and I love that move so I'm not embarrassed to say I love it so much and I've seen it a lot of times and one of the things I really love about it you kind of touched on this whole idea of it can't wait for the musical version no 97 by the way 1997 which is insane that's what I came out wow it seems like two
没有人提前通知你，没有人说过这一侧会有一个人着火，这一切……这是一种非常有趣、非常独特的恐慌，你知道的。这很有趣，这有点呼应你刚才所说的话，我喜欢那部电影的原因之一——我真的很喜欢那部电影，所以我并不羞于承认我有多喜欢它，我看了很多遍，而我真正喜欢它的其中一点，你刚才也提到了这个整的概念……等不及看音乐剧版本了！不，那是 1997 年的事，顺便说一句，1997 年，这太疯狂了。那就是它上映的时候，哇，感觉就像
years ago but you had that moment where your character is a school teacher I think is that right or yeah yeah we just school but the idea that it doesn't matter what he is he's just a regular this is what the thing of this particularly this war there was the Great War which they referred to World War 1 as but then there was the war this war World War 2 and he was a guy who was called to do something extraordinary he wasn't a guy who was born to be a military officer he wasn't a guy who's born to be a killer he was a guy who had to go because that's what he had to do and people came in in this moment when
两年前一样。但你有这样一个时刻：你的角色是一个学校老师，我想是这样吗？或者……是的，我们只是学校（里的老师）。但那种理念是，他是什么人并不重要，他只是一个普通人。这就是这场战争的特殊之处——曾有“伟大战争”（人们把第一次世界大战称为大战争），但随后有了“那场战争”，这场战争，第二次世界大战。他是一个被召唤去做出非凡之事的人，他不是生来就是军官的人，他不是生来就是杀手的人，他是一个不得不去的人，因为那是他必须做的事。而人们在那个时刻挺身而出，
the entire world was at war and did extraordinary things and I always loved that about it and I think that for me it really captured what it is that that sort of makes me have such a it's weird to have say have reverence for the war but you have reverence for the bravery and what people did that was extraordinary things yeah you actually want to make an anti-war movie at the same time right that you're making a war movie right let me tell you a story I was I was night 18 years old I think and I was a Belman at the Royal Hotel in Oakland California and we had a guy who read his own dry cleaning service would
当全世界都陷入战争时，做出了非凡的事情。我一直很喜欢这一点，我觉得对我来说，它真正捕捉到了那种……让我对战争产生一种……对战争产生敬畏感其实很奇怪，但你对那种勇敢以及人们所做出的非凡事情怀有敬畏，是的。你其实想在制作一部战争电影的同时拍一部反战电影，对吧？让我给你讲个故事。我当时……我大概 18 岁，是加利福尼亚州奥克兰皇家酒店的一名门童。我们那儿有个家伙，负责他自己的干洗服务，他会
come and collect the clothes and take them away and then deliver the clean clothes he was always coming with you know dozens and dozens of shirts and pants that have been dry cleaned and I was working there one summer and he was gone for two weeks I'm gonna say his name was Mike I can't remember what his name was but Mike was gone for two weeks and somebody else came in every day and then then after two weeks it was in June after two weeks he came back from his vacation I said oh hey Mike where were these last two oh no I take a vacation every every every June I said oh oh do you do you go camping no no no I I get
来收走衣服，把它们带走，然后再把洗干净的衣服送回来。他总是带着……你知道的，几十件甚至上百件已经干洗过的衬衫和裤子。我在那里做了一个夏天的工，然后他离开了两周。我要说的是，他的名字叫迈克，我不记得他叫什么名字了，但迈克离开了两周，每天都有另一个人来。然后两周后——那是六月份——两周后他度假回来了。我说：“噢，嘿，迈克，这两周你去哪儿了？”“噢，不，我每年六月都要度个假。”我说：“噢，噢，你是去露营吗？”“不，不，我
together with with some of my old buddies and said oh oh where did you where did you go well this this year we we went back to this place that we had visited back when we were kids I said oh no where was that he said that it's in the it's in the north of France he was a paratrooper he was in the 82nd airborne wow this guy is nice well I'm this 1974 so go back 40 years so he's he's in his 50s and what he's telling me is that when he was in his 20s he jumped into he jumped into Normandy on D-Day and he was a paratrooper and now he's a guy delivering his dry cleaning dry cleaning for the hotel yeah I felt I felt
和几个老战友聚在一起。”我说：“噢，你们去哪儿了？”“嗯，今年我们回到了那个我们小时候去过的地方。”我说：“噢，那是哪儿？”他说：“那在法国北部。”他是一名伞兵，他曾在美军第 82 空降师。哇，这家伙……好。好吧，我当时是 1974 年，往前推 40 年，所以他当时五十多岁。他告诉我的事情是，当他二十多岁时，他在 D 日那天跳伞降落在诺曼底，他是一名伞兵。而现在，他是一个为酒店送干洗衣服的干洗工。是的，我觉得
stupid and small but also that was a he was an example of that adult that caregiver that was part of daily life that you know that he didn't know if he was gonna make it back and he went oh he said and we go back he said this he said we go back to visit the buddies that didn't make it home so they're visiting the visiting the the cemetery sitter in so look that's a generation it was a it was a time that was loaded with all sorts of problems that of course we're still dealing with right now but you can't take away the fact that these were young guys who were asked to go off and liberate the world from really
自己又愚蠢又渺小，但这也是一个例子——那种成年人，那种作为日常生活一部分的照顾者，你知道的，他当时根本不知道自己能不能活着回来。他说：“我们回去……”他这么说：“我们回去看望那些没能回家的战友。”所以他们去拜访、去参观那些墓地。所以看吧，那是一个时代，它充满了各种各样的问题，当然我们现在也依然在处理这些问题，但你无法抹杀这样一个事实：这些都是年轻人，他们被要求去把世界从那些真正、
really bad people and they did it yeah my grandfather I just I'll leave it at this my my grandfather who passed almost almost 12 years ago was really close with and loved dearly he I remember him telling me he worked with he was in the Canadian Army but he was attached to the Royal Air Force and he planned bombing sorties and they were stationed at various air airfields as they would move across as they you know after June 44 and he said one morning we wake up and there was constantly planes taking off and landing and stuff and they were right and he said one morning his tent the guy we shared a tent with woke up
真正邪恶的人手中解放出来，而且他们做到了。是的，我的祖父……我只想用这个来收尾。我的祖父在几乎 12 年前去世了，我与他非常亲近并且深爱着他。我记得他告诉我……他在加拿大军队工作，但被派驻到皇家空军，他规划轰炸任务，随着他们的推进（在 1944 年 6 月之后），他们驻扎在不同的飞机场。他说有一天早晨我们醒来，当时不断有飞机起降什么的，他们就在旁边。他说有一天早晨，他的帐篷……我们合住一个帐篷的那个家伙醒来，
came out of the tent and walked into a propeller of a plane in the dark and I said and he told me he didn't tell me this until I was about 18 of course and I said well what did you do and he said and he wasn't joking he said well I got a new tent mate and I was like wow and he was just like that's the way it went we had to keep going there was what can you do I don't want to go into place I was that's too much of a bummer of a story sad story true story very so anyway I think a perfect segue would be happy days right in order to make saving private Ryan happen or any of the other incredible movies that you have you I am
从帐篷里出来，在黑暗中直接走进了飞机的螺旋桨。我说……他直到我大约 18 岁时才告诉我这件事，当然。我说：“那你做了什么？”他说——他当时不是在开玩笑——他说：“嗯，我换了个新帐篷舍友。”我当时想：“哇！”他当时就是那种态度：“事情就是这样，我们必须继续前进，你能怎么办呢？”我不想进入那个境地……那是个太扫兴的故事了，一个悲伤的故事，但也是真实的故事。所以无论如何，我觉得一个完美的过渡应该是《欢乐时光》（Happy Days），对吧？为了让《拯救大兵瑞恩》得以实现，或者让你参与的任何其他不可思议的电影实现，你……我是在
db reading son no no no no this is pure Wikipedia so so had you not booked that episode on happy days hey would you have not met Ron Howard and things that we would not have been gifted the highlight Ron Howard on happy days Ron had left the series by then what I the guys I met were Lowell Gans and Babalu Mandel who were the staff writers on happy days who wrote the the part who wrote Splash the screenplay of Splash and Ron was directing and they said hey mate want to take a look at that guy who got fired from bosom buddies you know bosom buddies was canceled something that Sean is going to experience one of these
读 IMDb 吗？不，不，不，不，这纯粹是维基百科！所以，如果你当初没有接下《欢乐时光》那一集，嘿，你会不会就遇不到朗·霍华德了？我们也就不会拥有朗·霍华德在《欢乐时光》里的光芒了？朗当时已经离开这个系列了。我遇到的人是洛厄尔·甘斯和巴布卢·曼德尔，他们是《欢乐时光》的编剧，他们写了……写了《美人鱼》的剧本，而朗当时在导演。他们说：“嘿，老兄，想去看看那个被《乌龙搭档》解雇的家伙吗？”你知道的，《乌龙搭档》被砍了，这是肖恩
days yeah don't worry Sean's canceled two programs I've been on so keep going and we will be right back and now back to the show Tom would you agree that the this the routine of a sitcom actor is the best job in show business do you miss it still to this day well it is it is kind of a skate it's a great hang I'll tell you that because look if you either shoot you will rehearse Monday Tuesday Wednesday camera block Thursday shoot Friday right or you rehearse Thursday Friday Monday camera block Tuesday shoot Wednesday is that kind of like that that second one shoots Tuesday yes you start on Wednesday what
总有一天会经历的事。是的，别担心，肖恩已经被砍过两个我参加过的节目了。所以我们继续，广告之后马上回来。现在回到节目中。汤姆，你同意吗？情景喜剧演员的日常工作是演艺界最好的工作吗？直到今天你还怀念它吗？嗯，它确实……它有点像是一种滑过去的生活，那是一个很棒的消遣，我得这么说。因为你看，要么你拍摄时……你周一、周二、周三排练，周四摄像机走位排练，周五拍摄；或者你周四、周五、周一排练，周二摄像机走位，周三拍摄。是不是那种……第二种是周二拍摄？对，你从周三开始……
you're saying is five days of the week yeah yeah unless you're working with Jimmy Burroughs and then you can take the first day off of rehearsal and really becomes a four-day work week and it's only three weeks a month so it's 12 working days a month these are really top-secret things man you should never let the civilians here are you blowing up and it's six hours a day now everybody's gonna want to be in showbiz there's there's there's there's craft service climate gets a lot of breaks you know it is it is an awfully awfully fun day given when we did bosom buddies Peter Scallari and I my dear old
你的意思是每周五天。对，对，除非你跟吉米·伯罗斯合作，那样的话你可以把排练的第一天省下来，真的变成了一个四周工作四天的工作周。而且一个月只有三周，所以一个月是 12 个工作日。这些真的是绝密的事情，老兄，你绝不能让平民们听到这个。你在大放厥词！而且现在每天只工作六小时，所有人都会想进演艺圈了。那里有后勤餐饮，有很多休息时间，你知道的，这真的是一段非常、非常有趣的日子。当时我们拍《乌龙搭档》时，彼得·斯卡拉里和我——我亲爱的老搭档，演过伟大的剧集——我们实际上是用录像带拍那个节目的，而不是用电影摄影机。那年头的电影摄影机……摄像机走位那天基本上就像是你的站位排练。但我们有四台摄像机，我们必须自己把整个摄像机走位的过程在镜头前演完，因为他们要做现场导播切换，你知道的：“切到三号机，四号机推紧，四号机，让我们切回二号机，二号机切回来……”你必须全程都在场配合。所以你工作时间很长，把那一周剧本的每一句台词一遍又一遍地演。我和他开始胡闹得太厉害了，
pal one of the great shows we actually shot that show on video not on the film cameras film cameras in those days that was pretty much a bunt camera camera blocking day was just kind of like your stand and did it but we had four video cameras and we had to do the entire camera blocking day ourselves on camera because they did a line cut you know camera three and tighten up on four and four let's come back let's coming back to two and two you had to be there for that so you did you worked a long day and you did every line of the that week script over and over again and he and I just started goofing around so much that
所以……那是我们第一次……我们被吼了好几次，你知道的，控制室里的导演（你知道的），他会用那高高在上的“上帝之音”介入：“嘿，伙计们，我们在努力工作呢，你们能稍微收敛一下、直接念台词吗？不然我们没法做现场切镜了。我们在试着核对三号机上的返送灯呢，汤姆，那个亮起就代表你在说话……”而我们根本不在乎，我们只是在胡闹。当你得到那个节目时，你有多兴奋？那是怎样的一个时刻？年轻的汤姆·汉克斯得到了《乌龙搭档》，你拿到了这个角色，这是你的工作，那是怎样……嗯，我简直
that's that's where we first got we got yelled at a couple of times you know the the the director up in the booth you know he'd come in over that top voice of God hey guys listen we're working really hard on can you guys just cut it skip to the lines otherwise we can't get the line cut in we're trying check the tally lights on camera three Tom would that comes on that you know you speak and we didn't care we were just goofing around so much how excited were you when you got when you got that show what was that moment so young Tom Hanks and you get bosom buddies you booked it it's your job what was that well I couldn't
不敢相信，是的。我要上电视了，你知道的，没错。而且在那之前，作为一名莎士比亚戏剧演员，我一整年赚的钱甚至不到一万美元，而我已经结婚了，还有一个孩子。天哪，我在《乌龙搭档》里两周就赚到了几乎……我赚到了那么多钱！所以财务上的解脱是巨大的。你上一次演莎士比亚是什么时候？我两岁……两年前在洛杉矶演过莎士比亚，我演了福斯塔夫，是的，在洛杉矶莎士比亚中心。汤姆，讲讲那个故事。那是一个我看到的你表演的视频，我不记得了，太搞笑了，你从……
believe it yeah I was gonna be on TV you know right and I was gonna be up to that point as a Shakespearean actor I'd made I made less than ten ten thousand dollars in a year for an entire year and I was married and I had a kid and geez I made almost I made that in two weeks on on bosom buddies so the financial reprieve was huge when was the last time you did Shakespeare I did Shakespeare two years ago here in Los Angeles I played false staff yes with the Shakespeare Center Los Angeles Tom tell that story it was it was a video that I saw of you doing it I can't remember it was so funny you pulled some guy out of the
观众席里拉了个人上来还是怎么着？那是什么？不，当时的情况是，我们遇到了一个医疗紧急情况，一位先生突发心脏问题，突然之间不得不叫救护车。我们当时是在西洛杉矶的退伍军人中心、桉树林中的日本花园里演出。你知道的，有个家伙突发某种癫痫，我们不得不叫急救医疗人员，然后我们不得不暂停演出。“屋里”——不是屋里的灯，所有的灯都亮了，最后演变成大约 30 分钟的暂停，当时他们在照顾那个人，对吧？我们所有人都在后台说：“我们该做点什么吗？”
audience or something what was no what happened was we had it we had a medical emergency a guy a gentleman had a heart thing happened to him and all of a sudden the paramedics had to be called we were doing it at the VA Center in the Japanese Garden amongst the Eucalyptus trees here in West Los Angeles and you know that a guy had some sort of seizure and we had to call the EMTs and then we had to take a break in the house not the house lights the lights all came up and it was going into it ended up being about a 30 minute hold while they took care of the right and we were all backstage saying should we do something
然后当我看到人们开始离开……噢，不，不，不，不，不，我的意思是，这是一场很长的演出，无论如何本来也快要演三个小时了。但当我看到人们……我看到一位女士拿起她的手提包朝出口走去，我冲了出去，试图大喊：“你给我回来！回到你的座位上去，或者诸如此类的话！”是的，太搞笑了！但神奇的是，你居然用莎士比亚式的腔调进行即兴表演！那就是让我震惊的地方，而且超级搞笑！天哪，太棒了！结果证明这一切都是值得的，拉住了足够多的人留下来，而且我觉得我嘲讽了足够多的人，以至于把某个
and then when I saw that people were leaving oh no no no no no no I mean it was gonna it was a long it was about close to three hour show anyway but when I saw people I saw a lady pick up her purse and move toward the exit and I came running out trying to scream and she get back here take take thee thy seat or something yeah it was so funny but what was amazing was you were improvising in Shakespearean talk that was that's what my mind and it was super funny God it was so great it ended up it ended up being worthwhile and got enough people to stay and I think I ridiculed enough people that made some
女士（因为大笑/喜极而泣）逗哭了。那是怎样的……你知道的，比如《美人鱼》，很多年前为了你的生日，我给你寄了一张海报，我把我的脸P到了达丽尔·汉娜的脸上，上面写着：“你和我本可以掀起更大的波澜，但我们只是开拓者而已。”但你知道吗，那是怎样的感觉？那种感受是什么？因为作为一个小孩子，我当时想：“噢，天哪，每个演员都想成为汤姆·汉克斯！每个人，每个演员都想成为你！”因为你参演了所有这一连串巨大的喜剧热门作品，对吧？《飞越未来》和《美人鱼》，以及……我当时在做什么？他们让我……
lady cry you know out of laughter tears of joy what was the you know a splash by the way for your birthday years and years ago I sent you a poster and I superimposed my face over Daryl Hannah's and I said the note said you and I would have made a bigger splash but we only been the trailblazers but but you know what was that like what was that feeling because as a kid I was like oh my god every actor wanted to be Tom thanks everybody every actor wanted to be you yeah because you were in all of the string of these massive comedy hits right and big and splash and just what I was doing they asked me to they asked me
他们让我参演一部电影，所以我说好。但你当时知道吗？当你开始拍所有那些其他电影时——你拍了《飞越未来》，你拍了所有这些，它们正变得……你知道你要去哪里吗？不，不，我们毫无头脑。他们只是说……没有计划，你扮演主角，而且你极具个人魅力，你在银幕上非常有吸引力，你一出道就能挑大梁。你从小到大一直都很有自信并且具备这种领导才能吗？我当时只是在努力记住台词，我只是在努力说得足够大声以便被人听见。但汤姆，你……
to be in a movie so I said yeah but did you but did you know when you started doing all those other movies started you did big and you did all these things and they were just getting did you know where you were going or no no we have no idea they just said no plan you were playing the lead and you are incredibly charismatic and you were you were you were compelling on screen like you were carrying things right out of the gate had you always had the confidence and these sort of the leadership qualities growing up I was just trying to remember the words I was trying to speak loud enough to be heard but Tom you are
你真的是……太让人如释重负了。听着，我来告诉你……我学到的最大、最大的一课，这是我在大湖莎士比亚戏剧节的时候——就在离我现在只有一天车程的俄亥俄州莱克伍德。丹·沙利文导演了那场……我演的《亨利四世》里的福斯塔夫，他于 1977 年执导了那部戏。我们当时在轮演剧团，我拿着长矛，我做着所有被要求去做的事情。我们刚刚在前一晚首演了一部《哈姆雷特》，那是轮演剧团的模式——差不多每两周首演一部剧，然后每晚演不同的剧，这就是“轮演剧目”的意思，肖恩。
you are you are such a relief listen I'll tell you I'll tell you the biggest the biggest lesson that I learned this was when I was at the Great Lakes Shakespeare Festival just a day's drive from where I am right now in Lakewood Ohio and which Dan Sullivan he's a who directed the the the fault the Henry the fifth excuse me Henry the fourth that I did his false death he directed that in 1977 we were in rotating rep and I was carrying a spear and I was doing everything that I was told to do and we had done that we had just opened a production of Hamlet the night before it was in rotating rep so you open the
所以我们刚刚首演了《哈姆雷特》，第二天我们所有人都要为《驯悍记》排练——我在《驯悍记》里扮演格鲁米奥（Grumio）。所有的演员公会成员、专业演员们都宿醉未醒、精疲力竭，因为他们前一晚都出去狂欢了，因为他们刚刚首演了《哈姆雷特》。所以每个人都像梦游一样在 10 点钟出现，根本没人记住自己的台词，每个人都在那儿拖着步子走来走去，然后丹·沙利文大吼了一声——
shows about every two weeks and then you ran a different show every night that's what repertory means Sean and so we had opened up Hamlet and we all had to rehearsal the next day for a taming of the shrew which I played I played Grumio in timming of the shrew and all of the equity company the professionals were hungover exhausted because they had all been out partying the night before because they just opened Hamlet so everybody was like synambulistic and showing up at 10 o'clock and no one really knew their lines yet and everybody was kind of like shuffling around and Dan Sullivan yelled at
演出大约每两周更换一次，每天晚上都有不同的剧目，肖恩，这就是保留剧目的意思。我们刚上演了《哈姆雷特》，第二天大家就得去排练《驯悍记》，我在《驯悍记》里演格鲁米奥。所有剧团的专业演员都宿醉未醒、筋疲力尽，因为他们前一晚才刚演完《哈姆雷特》出去狂欢了，所以大家都像梦游一样，十点钟晃晃悠悠地来排练，谁也没记住台词，大家都在那儿磨磨蹭蹭的，然后丹·沙利文大声训斥了
everybody he yelled at everybody said hey hey hey hey we've got three weeks to get this show up on its feet and you people are not even trying for crying out loud I can't do my job if you guys don't do your jobs you guys have got a show up on time you got to know your lines and you've got to have an idea I can't provide everything here so let's take a break mainline some coffee chew it if you have to right out of the jar but come back here with some friggin energy fuck I would cast you in the Dan Sullivan movie right now by the way sorry just for what it's worth that was okay so you look we're all we're all like
每个人 他冲每个人大喊 嘿嘿嘿嘿 我们只有三个星期来让这个节目排练好 你们这些家伙根本就没在努力 拜托了 如果你们不做好自己的工作 我就没法完成我的工作 你们必须准时到场 必须背熟台词 还要有自己的想法 我无法在这里提供所有东西 所以我们休息一下 直接来点咖啡 如果必须的话直接从罐子里嚼也行 但回来时得拿出点该死的干劲 靠 我现在就把你选进丹·沙利文的电影里 顺便说一句 抱歉 仅此而已 那还可以 所以你看 我们大家都……
1918 20 I was 20 years old then and that lesson really super stuck to me if professional actors who have 20 years in the biz as they often said 20 years in the biz I've never been yelled at like that that was that was an important lesson all through all of these gigs that I had the hits thank you the Mrs. let's forget those I always that was always the thing that I thought be most important thing to do was show up on time know your lines and have an idea in your pocket for sure bring it that's that's all I did through all of those I didn't know anything so Tom when you went when you were doing all the strings
1918 20岁 我那时20岁 那个教训深深地印在了我脑子里 如果在这一行干了20年的专业演员 —— 正如他们常说的 20年在这一行 —— 从来没被那样大吼大叫过 那真的是一个重要的教训 在我接下来的所有演出中 那些大获成功的 谢谢你 那些烂片 咱们就忘了吧 我总是 —— 那一直是我认为最重要的事情 就是准时到场 熟悉台词 并且口袋里随时准备好一个想法 把它拿出来 真的 这就是我在所有那些演出中做的全部 我什么都不懂 所以汤姆 当你当时在拍……
at the string of comedies back then and you do you remember what it felt like or do you remember that pivot moment when all of a sudden maybe you got offered a script or you had a kind of dialogue with your agent or what happened where you switched over to more let's say important films or more dramatic films and what a way to what a question is so great you were you okay I that was the era of you can make a movie for about $15 million and if you just said it was a comedy it seemed to do some brand of business whether it was actually funny or not it didn't matter yeah that was it was all you know anybody who had said
拍那一连串喜剧的时候 你还记得那是什么感觉吗 或者你还记得那个转折点吗？当时可能有人给你递了剧本 或者是你和经纪人有过某种对话 或者是发生了什么事让你转向了 比如说更重要的电影 或者更有戏剧性的电影 这算什么问题 太棒了 你没事吧 我 —— 那是个可以用大约1500万美元拍一部电影的时代 如果你宣称这是一部喜剧 似乎总能做成某种生意 不管它实际上好不好笑 真的无所谓 是的 那就是 —— 你知道 任何一个喊……
action and cut was trusted to direct a comedy movie whether they were funny or not and I'm I made a I made a ton of those in which everybody came at all the dailies were fantastic I think the audience is going to be standing on their feet at the end of this so Tracy dailies are the thing you watch as you're filming the movie they get the Russians the day before stuff and it doesn't matter if the movie was called monkeys make the sun go down everybody was in this is this is the funniest of all the cows of tumble town this is going to be a magnificent comedy because the good comedies that were made you know at the
“开拍”和“停”的人都被信任可以导演一部喜剧电影 不管他们好不好笑 我 —— 我拍了海量的这种电影 每个人来的时候 所有每日毛片都棒极了 我想观众在这结束时都会起立鼓喝 所以 崔西 每日毛片就是你在拍电影时观看的东西 他们在前一天拿到冲洗出来的胶片 不管这部电影叫《猴子让太阳下山》还是别的什么 每个人都觉得 这是 这一切里最好笑的奶牛镇喜剧 这将是一部宏伟的喜剧 因为当时拍出的好喜剧……
time they all had they were all with former second city people you know and setting up live people and but there was this this you could take a setting this movie takes place on a ski slope this movie takes place on a school bus this movie takes place at a bachelor party and it will be a comedy and I made a I made a billion of those like that because we're just kind of like doing imitations of other people's funny movies yeah but here's the thing and I've said this about there are a few people out there who have this and you are one of them which is it doesn't matter what the movie was you are always good you're
它们都有 —— 它们都是和前第二城（Second City）的人一起拍的 你知道的 安排现场的人 而且还有这种 —— 你可以设定一个场景 这部电影发生在一个滑雪场 这部电影发生在一辆校车上 这部电影发生在一个单身派对上 它就会是一部喜剧 我拍了像这样的上亿部这样的电影 因为我们只是在模仿别人的搞笑电影 是的 但关键是 —— 我曾经说过这一点 有少数人拥有这种特质 而你就是其中之一 也就是说 不管是什么电影 你总是表现得很棒 你总是……
always even even doing I joked about doing the Dan Sullivan no matter what it is you're committed and that always kind of shines through so I I know that you talked about those those misses I mean look if it wasn't for bad movies I wouldn't make any at all you wouldn't be sitting in your dad's library living back at my folks house but you know but it's true and you always you always deliver in that way because I always get the impression watching you that like you don't care what the thing is you're just doing I mean you're part of it and you're in the thing and who gives a shit what I don't want to I don't want to
总是 —— 甚至连我开玩笑说拍丹·沙利文的电影时也是如此 不管是什么 你都全力以赴 这一点总是能展现出来 所以我知道你谈到过那些失败之作 我的意思是 听着 要不是因为烂电影 我根本就不会拍任何电影 你就不会坐在你爸爸的书库里住在我父母家了 但你知道的 —— 但这是真的 你总是能以那种方式带来精彩的表现 因为我看着你时总是有一种印象 就像你根本不在乎这是什么东西 你只是在做 —— 我的意思是 你是其中的一部分 你身处其中 谁在乎到底是什么 —— 我不想 —— 我不想……
discount some of the great stuff I met great people and we did we made we actually did some really funny stuff that that that really did work and yes always always fun also known as classics it was well you know it's funny you know they I don't think I we ever had a movie Splash was well reviewed and I don't think I had another decent review for about I don't know six or seven films but now you read about them and they're they're called classics you know they're called classic now didn't happen back in the day but once Philadelphia happened I would imagine some of the scripts that were coming to
贬低一些伟大的作品 我遇到了很棒的人 我们做过 —— 我们确实拍了一些真正好笑的东西 那些东西 —— 真的是奏效的 而且是的 —— 总是 总是很有趣 也就是所谓的经典 呃 好吧 你知道这很有趣 你知道 —— 我不认为 —— 我觉得我们从来没有过一部 —— 《美人鱼》获得了很好的评论 我想我大概有六七部电影再也没有得到过像样的评论 但现在你读到关于它们的文章时 它们都被称为 —— 它们被称为经典了 你知道的 它们现在被称为经典了 当年可没有这样 但自从《费城故事》之后 我想象一些送上门来的剧本……
you started to confuse things for you and your team well I got older you know that that's the other thing too I you know there's a type of movie you can make in your late 20s I turned here's a story I turned 27 the day of we wrapped the motion picture Splash it was the last day of shooting we were in the Bahamas we had a cake that was actually for the wrap hey let's celebrate the last day of shooting with a cake and someone I think with the tube of toothpaste added in icing on the cake happy birthday Tom because they found out it was my birthday so that was you know there's a movie that you make when
开始让你和你的团队感到困惑了 嗯 我变老了 你知道 —— 这也是另一回事 我 —— 你知道 有一种电影是你快27岁时可以拍的 我转 —— 这有个故事 我拍完电影《美人鱼》的那天刚好27岁 那是拍摄的最后一天 我们在巴哈马 我们的蛋糕其实是为了杀青准备的 嘿 让我们用一个蛋糕来庆祝杀青的最后一天 结果有人 —— 我想是带着一管牙膏 —— 在蛋糕上用糖霜写着 “汤姆生日快乐” 因为他们发现那天是我的生日 所以那是 —— 你知道的 有一部电影是你……
you're 27 and in your early 30s and one have done you know I made I made a number of them and which but you have to get older you know you can't yeah and I was able to age into Gary Marshall gave me a great role with Jackie Gleason in a movie called nothing in common and then David Seltzer wrote and directed with Sally Field punchline and then big came along that's great yeah but you get older and so and you start singing I will tell you I look I'm not big on this kind of stuff but there was one time I was sitting around with my crack showbiz expert who works for CAA and he said to me what do you want to do and I and I
27岁和30岁出头时拍的 我拍过 —— 我拍过好几部这样的电影 但你必须变老 你知道 你不能 —— 是的 而我得以逐渐变老 加里·马歇尔给了我一个很好的角色 和杰克·莱蒙一起演了一部叫《悍妞 La La 操》的电影 然后大卫·塞尔策编剧并执导了由萨莉·菲尔德主演的《爆笑n站》 然后《飞越未来》出现了 这很棒 是的 但你变老了 所以 —— 你开始看 —— 我得告诉你 听着 我不太热衷于这种事 但有一次我正和我的顶尖演艺界专家坐在一起 他为CAA工作 他对我说 你想做什么 我 —— 我……
said you know exactly like Richard that's a great impersonation there you go beautiful what do you want to do and I said I said I want to play grown-ups so I want to I want to play people who've been through bitter compromise because that was I was in my mid 30s by that point compromise Jason is a thing that people do yeah when you hear the other person's side and then you go okay I'm willing to shift my position a little bit and whatever we'll talk about it later until sorry time wait time you know what I was wanted to ask you and this is gonna be the dumbest question in the world but I'm guaranteed but that's
说 你知道的 就像理查德那样 那是个很棒的模仿 太棒了 你想做什么 我说 我说我想演成年人 所以我想 —— 我想演那些经历过痛苦妥协的人 因为那是 —— 我当时已经35岁左右了 妥协 杰森 是人们会做的事 是的 当你听到对方的观点 然后你说 好吧 我愿意稍微改变一下我的立场 随便啦 我们以后再聊 抱歉 汤姆 等等 汤姆 你知道的 我一直想问你 这将是世上最蠢的问题 但我保证 —— 但那是……
right in castaway right you the volleyball is named Wilson now you're married to the wonderful Rita Wilson who I love I adore we all do is is was that by design because it could have been called spaulding Jesus could have been it was written by Bill broils and that man that movie took about six years to figure out Bill broils and I started talking about it and we didn't we weren't shooting it until six years later and he came up with the idea of a volleyball and he named it Wilson in honor of my beautiful bride we've been married it'll be 34 years hold for a pause hold for a pause yeah thank you
对了 在《荒岛余生》里 对不对 那个排球叫威尔逊 现在你嫁给了美妙的丽塔·威尔逊 我爱她 我崇拜她 我们所有人都这样 这 —— 这是刻意安排的吗 因为它本来可以叫斯伯丁的 上帝啊 它是由威廉·布罗伊斯写的 那部电影花了大约六年时间才琢磨出来 威廉·布罗伊斯和我开始讨论它 我们直到六年之后才开始拍摄 他想出了一个排球的主意 并把它命名为威尔逊 以纪念我美丽的新娘 我们已经结婚了 —— 将是34年 暂停一下 暂停一下 是的 谢谢你……
well Jesus Christ that is a whole new level now you know but that brings me to Finch Finch seems like it's got some qualities it's I mean if I was a hack studio executive I'd say it's it's castaway meets Martian all movies are like that now all movies are like that yeah aren't they all essentially you take a it's this is on the waterfront meets pal Joey by by way of Paw Patrol they they're all movies are all come pop we have all but what you need is a is a relatable every man that is empathetic sympathetic can alpha and beta inside a page I mean you you are the man that could service all things I came up
天呐 这真的是一个全新的高度 现在你知道了 但这让我想到了芬奇 《芬奇》看起来确实有一些特质 我的意思是 如果我是一个平庸的制片厂高管 我会说它是 —— 它是《荒岛余生》遇上《火星救援》 现在所有的电影都这样 所有的电影现在都这样 是的 难道不是吗 它们本质上不都是 —— 你拿一个 —— 这是一个《码头风云》遇上《帕尔·乔伊》 顺便通过《汪汪队立大功》 —— 它们 —— 所有的电影都是大杂烩 我们都有 但你需要的是一个接地气的普通人 他富有同理心 同情心 能在页面上同时展现阿尔法和贝塔特质 我的意思是 你就是那个能够胜任所有事情的人 我是从……
through that era of which every genre movie was about somebody who could not be killed or defeated you know the cop that could not be filled I'm with you the fighter who could knew who never lost the and so I would you know a geeky guy with a big butt a big nose and a squeaky voice mm-hmm I took all the jobs away from will by the way I do have a big I have what's called a pro dumper yeah well you can't drive a spike with attack hammer as I have I just have a really quick castaway story that we might cut out of this but oh and Tom I think I told you this but I was working on Will and Grace with with
那个时代走过来的 当时每部电影的类型都是关于一个无法被杀死或击败的人 你知道的 那个无法被消灭的警察 我懂你 那个从不失败的格斗家 所以我 —— 你知道的 一个有着大屁股 大鼻子和尖嗓音的极客家伙 嗯哼 我把威廉所有的工作都抢走了 顺便说一句 我确实有一个大 —— 我有一个所谓的“专业倾倒器” —— 是的 噢 你不能用图钉锤去钉大铁钉 我只是 —— 我有一个非常短的《荒岛余生》故事 我们可能会把它从这里剪掉 但 —— 噢 汤姆 我想我跟你说过这个 但我当时在拍《威尔和格蕾丝》 与一个……
somebody worked on the show and we went after to his house after a taping one night and we got super super super stoned and will know this won't be cut yeah we had super super super stoned and he he said look I got a copy of castaway I got the DVD let's fast forward it to the plane crash because the effects are so crazy let's get totally high and watch like how do they do that right and so we so he just moved in this house it was this brand new equipment and we're and I'm sitting in the back of his screening room and he's up front he just moved into this crazy houses gorgeous and he had no idea how his own
在剧组工作的人一起有一天晚上拍摄结束后我们去了他家然后我们抽得超级超级超级大麻味十足威廉知道这个不会被剪掉是的我们超级超级大麻味十足然后他说你看我有一份《荒岛余生》我有一张DVD让我们快进到飞机失事因为特效太疯狂了我们嗨翻天然后看看他们是怎么做到的对吧所以我们 —— 所以他刚搬进这栋房子 这是全新的设备 我们 —— 我坐在他的放映室后面 他在前面他刚搬进这个疯狂的房子里 简直太华丽了 他完全不知道他自己的……
equipment worked and so sitting in the backseat and he can't get the DVD to play and I said oh no that's is that a Sony totally high out of my mind I goes that is Sony he goes yeah I go oh their voice activated those are the new ones you don't even know what you have you have to speak the name of the movie into the machine after you put it in because what are you talking about I go just listen to me you have to say the name of the movie as you put it into the DVD player he's like are you serious I go a hundred percent I just read about these so he turns back to the machine with his back to me and he goes castaway and it
设备是怎么运作的 所以坐在后排座 他没办法让DVD播放 我说 噢 不 那是 —— 那是索尼吗？我当时嗨得神志不清 我说 那是索尼 他说 是的 我说 噢 它们的语音激活的 那些是新款的 你甚至都不知道你拥有什么 你必须把电影的名字对着机器说出来 在你把它放进去之后 他说你在说什么 我说 听着我的 你必须把电影的名字说出来 当你把它放进DVD播放机时 他就像是 你是认真的吗 我说 百分之百 我刚读到过这些 所以他转过身去面对机器 背对着我 他说 荒岛余生 然后它……
didn't play and he'd waited to be and they did it again he goes castaway and I turned behind me I was I couldn't breathe I was laughing Bob Zemeckis on that he needs he never cuts to the outside of the plane that's one of the reasons why that that plane crashes is good just from the perspective of inside the plane yeah I like that kind of stuff there that's Bob now Tom with all of your incredible set experience was that what drew you was it part of what drew you to the director's chair just just just the the effort to sort of streamline things because you knew probably more than a lot of the directors
没有播放 他等着 —— 然后他又试了一次 他说 荒岛余生 我转过身去 我简直喘不过气来 我笑得不行 罗伯特·泽米吉斯在那上面 —— 他从不切到飞机外部 那就是那架飞机失事之所以精彩的原因之一 仅仅是从飞机内部的视角来看 是的 我喜欢那种东西 那是鲍勃 那么 汤姆 凭着你所有不可思议的片场经验 是什么吸引了你 —— 这也是吸引你坐上导演椅的原因之一吗？仅仅是 —— 仅仅是为了简化事情的努力 因为你可能比很多导演都知道得更多……
you may have been working with no I think directing in that becomes sort of a bit of an ego thing because you become convinced that you know more than you actually do but Jason seriously yeah but then you try it you're like oh my god this is hard I believe every actor should direct I think every director should have to act I think we should all be writing and producing because you find out how hard it is to do that other job for sure from an actor's perspective it's like you know you got somebody saying that was pretty good try it again and you want to say to him do you realized I'm on a horse weeping
你可能一直在和他们合作 不 我认为导演在那个时候变成了一种有点像自我 ego 的东西 因为你变得坚信自己知道的其实比实际上更多 但杰森 说真的 是啊 但随后你尝试了 你就会想 天啊 这太难了 我相信每个演员都应该当导演 我认为每个导演都必须去表演 我认为我们都应该写作和制作 因为你会发现做另一份工作有多么困难 从演员的角度来看 这就像 —— 你知道 有人会对你说 “演得挺好 再试一次” 而你想对他说 你意识到我正骑在马上痛哭流涕……
because my dog died and I'm trying to remember six pages of dialogue at the same you do you realize it's a little harder than it is man let's try it again that along with the same thing of an actress saying hey we gonna shoot this or what are we shooting or what right you have to realize that everybody has nine million things going on inside their head and then and also we look we're all storytellers at some point we we can have a sense of what might fit into our mouths a little bit better and maybe some options it goes back to the thing Dan Sullivan always said which have an idea in your pocket you know
因为我的狗死了 而且我同时在努力记住六页的台词吗 你意识到这比看起来要难一点吗 老兄 我们再试一次 这和演员说 “嘿 我们什么时候拍这个 还是我们在拍什么 或者是什 —— 对吧” 你必须意识到每个人脑子里都有九百万件不同的事情在进行 然后 —— 还有 我们看 我们都是讲故事的人 在某个时刻 我们会对什么可能更适合从我们嘴里说出来有一种感觉 也许还有一些备选项 这回到了丹·沙利文总是说的那句话 —— 口袋里随时准备一个想法 你知道的……
have something that you can come out and say this isn't on the page but let me let me show you something else so since you have directed when you do come to the set as an actor with an idea in your pocket are you sensitive to that there might actually be a plan in place that that director and that crew has been working on for weeks and that your idea might might might disassemble the house of my son there might not be room for it so then you try it once and they say don't do that and so and then you don't do it right you know it's pretty pretty relatively easy stuff is that desire to direct still still still burning in you
准备一些你可以拿出来说的话 “这不在剧本上 但让我 —— 让我给你展示点别的” 所以既然你当过导演 当你作为演员带着口袋里的想法来到片场时 你会对那个导演和剧组已经研究了数周的既定计划保持敏感吗？并且你的想法可能会 —— 拆散这栋房子 —— 可能没有它的空间 所以你试了一次 他们说 “别那样做” 然后 —— 然后你就没那样做 对吧 你知道的 这挺 —— 相对来说挺简单的 这种想当导演的渴望还在 —— 还在燃烧吗 还是……
or I can't say that I have the instinctive powers of being a director as an actor I think I know what I want to do read it and I think oh I know what direction I'll go to directing is a director requires a fidelity and a patience and an ability to communicate that after I've done it for the I've directed two feature films I've directed a number of episodes of the miniseries that we've done and I like those because I wrote them more I wrote on them at the same time but I think I think directors more so than than than myself as an actor they're they're born into it you know you had to think it's the greatest
我不能说我拥有作为演员的导演本能力量 我想我知道我想怎么演 然后我想 —— 我知道我会走向什么方向 导演需要一种忠诚度、耐心和沟通能力 在我做过这些之后 —— 我导演过两部故事片 我导演过我们做过的好几集迷你剧 我喜欢那些因为我写了更多 —— 我同时在上面进行了写作 但我认为 —— 我认为导演 —— 比 —— 比我作为演员 —— 他们是天生吃这碗饭的 你知道的 你得认为这是世界上最棒的工作……
job in the world yeah and oftentimes it's not yeah do you enjoy the producing part of it all with what what you guys don't really produce well but you guys churn out it's really you shouldn't sluff over it's the alliances that I make with other people that really do all the work but the amount of your bit you incredibly prolific as a producer you and Gary I mean it's it's you've employed an incredible amount of people you've put a lot of product out there that's not easy and that's it's incredibly admirable well I'm very lucky because we have extremely good people and we we do this you know we have a kind of like a
是的 而通常情况并非如此 是的 你喜欢其中的制片部分吗 凭着你们 —— 你们产出的那些 —— 真的 —— 你不应该轻描淡写这其实是我和其他人结成的联盟 真正完成了所有工作 但你的产量 —— 你作为一个制片人极其多产 你和加里 我的意思是 —— 这真的是 —— 你雇用了难以置信数量的人 你推出了大量的产品 这可不容易 这令人难以置信地令人钦佩 好吧 我非常幸运 因为我们有极其优秀的人 我们这样做 —— 你知道的 我们有一种类似俱乐部会所的办公室 我们把头探进彼此的门口说 “你知道这真的是一部故事片吗 伙计们 我不太确定这是一部故事片 不应该把它改成一部12集的迷你剧吗 这样我们就能真正审视这个主题了” 然后 —— 然后你结成了数不清的联盟 但这就是 —— 我不是一个制片人 因为这就是制片人们每天在做的事 他们拿起电话 试图说服某人去做他们绝对不想做的事 对吧 或者他们在电话里告诉某人 他们绝对不可能去做电话那头那个人 —— 差不多就是这样 就是那种……
clubhouse office where we lean in each other's doorway and say you know is this really a feature film guys I'm not so sure it's a feature film shouldn't be like a 12-part miniseries instead so we can really examine the theme and then then you make nothing but a ton of alliances but here's I'm not a producer because this is what producers do every day they get on the phone and they try to convince somebody to do something they do not want to do right or they tell somebody on the phone that there's no way that they are going to do what that person on the phone really that's pretty much it's that it's that
二分法 我总是无论别人说什么都说“好” 对吧 我们马上回来 现在回到节目中 我想问你 你对我们大家都在经历的这种向流媒体元素的转变有什么感觉？它与票房、院线（去电影院看电影、花钱买票）相结合 相对于在家观看 你作为业内人士对此有何看法？同时作为一个观众 你喜欢现在可能没有首周末票房压力的事实吗？因为……
dichotomy I always just say sure no matter no matter what they're saying right we'll be right back and now back to the show let me ask you how what is what's your feeling about this this transition that we're all in into a bit more of a streaming element married with you know box office you know theatrical you know going to the theater paying and paying some money for a ticket versus having it at home do you what is your opinion on that as somebody in the business and then also as somebody who is a who is a viewer is it do you like the fact that there is less pressure now maybe with not having to open on the weekend because
它是流媒体 你认为那是演员不需要承受的压力吗 因为听着 电影永远是二元的 它们要么是双零 要么是零一 它们要么成功 要么失败 如果它们失败了 无论做多少营销或采访 —— 你可以在播客上做的那种 —— 都无法改变时代精神 绝对的压力依然存在 压力就是光速 为了讲好一个故事 观众 —— 我如果能在这里稍微夸夸其谈一点的话 —— 请便 不在乎他们是在哪里看到的 商业运作、营销、制片人和制片厂……
it's streaming do you think that's that's a pressure that doesn't come upon the actor because look the movies are always binary they're either double zero or zero one they either work or they do not work and if they don't work there's no amount of marketing or interviews that you can do right on podcasts in order to in order to change the zeitgeist the the pressure remains absolute the pressure is the speed of light in order to make a great story the audience I think if I can pontificate just a little bit here please doesn't care where they see it the business does the marketing the producers in the studios
以及宏大的娱乐产业综合体 —— 你知道的 —— 他们会 —— 他们希望一切完全保持原样 但我们的业务永远在变 知道吗 回到1980年 当你们还在初中时 家庭录像的概念才刚开始 这里有个能追溯到很久以前的故事 当彼得和我第一年在《亲密伙伴》（Bosom Buddies）剧组时 一台VHS录像机、家里的播放机大约要4,000美元 是啊 哇哦 唯一拥有它们的人是极其富有的富豪 —— 用四分之三英寸的带子 —— 好吧 难道那时VHS不是……
in the the grand entertainment industrial complex you know they would you know they would like things to be exactly as they were but we have a business that is forever changing you know back in 1980 when you guys were still in junior high school and the concept of home video was just beginning here's a story that goes back a long way when we were the first year that Peter and I were in bosom buddies a VHS tape machine a player at home cost about $4,000 yeah wow and the only people that had them were incredibly wealthy rich peeping in the three-quarter inch for two well wasn't that by that time VHS was
刚刚开始吗 在某个街区里 可能有个叫道格的人会开一家“道格视频租赁店”（Doug's Video Rental Shoppe） 租赁空间的一边是VHS录像带 另一边是一个较小的索尼Beta-max磁带收藏 最后Beta磁带消失了 剩下的全都是VHS 等到我觉得第二年的时候 VHS录像机只需要大约1,800美元了 然后每个人都在租录像带 并且你可以 —— 能够录制节目这当然很棒 在经历了这种晦涩难懂的开机关机定时录像过程之后 但更重要的事情……
just beginning and in an in in a neighborhood maybe a guy named Doug would open up Doug's video rental shop SHO PPE and on one side of one side of the rental space would be VHS tapes and on the other side would be a smaller collection of beta Sony beta max and eventually beta went away and it was all just VHS and by the time I think the next year VHS machines were only like $1,800 and then everybody was renting and the concept that you could it was great of course to be able to record shows after you went through this arcane kind of like process of on off recording timing up but the bigger thing
是 —— 如果你有孩子 并且你有一大盘VHS的《小飞象》 你知道的 他们会自己在早上醒来 然后放进 —— 放进《小飞象》 你不必去买一个 —— 这太巨大了 而现在我们来到了2021年 行业正在经历类似于这种变化的变革 因为猜猜怎么着 正如我的合伙人加里·格茨曼所说 —— “坐在家里在电视上观看某些东西其实也没那么糟” 对不对 对不对 对不对 你知道的 汤姆 多年前你对我说 —— 你说 “你知道吗 肖恩 业务总是在变 你必须适应并随之改变” 作为演员或创作手艺本身……
was is that if you had kids and you had a big VHS of Dumbo you know they would get up in the morning on their own and put in put in Dumbo and you didn't have to get a bit this was huge and the here we are in 2021 and the industry is going through something akin to that change because guess what as Gary Getzman my partnered plate on said you know sitting at home and watching something on your TV is not that bad right right right you know Tom you said to me years ago you said you know what Sean the business is always changing and you have to adapt and change with it not as an actor or the craft of creating
事情 —— 你必须保持开放的心态 顺其自然 否则为什么 —— 如果你抗拒它 你只是 —— 你为什么不听那个建议 为什么不那样做 因为现在你沦落到了当主持人的地步 这是冷酷的 这是冷酷的 你被称为小飞象 —— 《小飞象》的主持人 我们非常幸运 我们在Playtone非常幸运 因为我们的第一笔交易之一就是在HBO 这是老派的HBO 你知道的 没有商业广告 你可以想说啥就说啥 没有语言限制 没有 —— 而且在那个时候 在HBO做剧集、电影或迷你剧 那就是黄金标准……
things just you have to keep an open mind and go with the flow of it otherwise why and if you fight it you're just why didn't you take that advice why didn't you do it because now you reduced to hosting is it heartless it's heartless you're known as Dumbo the host of we were very lucky we were very lucky at playtime because what our one of our first deals was at HBO and this was old-school HBO you know no commercials you could say anything you wanted to there was no language there was no there was no and at that point HBO doing so doing a series or a movie or a miniseries on HBO that was the gold
你拥有了似乎全世界所有的自由 而现在你拥有了更多那样的东西 —— 全世界所有的自由 但它仍然归结为这个非常基础的要求 你必须推出一个非常好的产品 否则它就会像我的许多早期电影一样消散在雾气中 谢谢你们 伙计们 不不不 但你怎么会没有 —— 我很惊讶 因为他们 —— 看起来他们试图吞下所有人 你怎么没有 —— 漫威什么时候给你打电话说 “汤姆 我们需要你来演 —— 宇宙博士” 并且 —— “我们需要你拍12部电影 你必须扮演宇宙博士” 那种事发生过吗……
standard you had seemed as though you had all the freedom in the world and now you have even more of that all the freedom in the world but it still comes down to this very basic requirement you've got to be putting out a an awfully good product otherwise it will disappear into the mist like many of my early films thanks guys no no no but how are you not I'm surprised because they it seems like they've tried to gobble up everybody how have you not as when did Marvel call you and say Tom we need you to play you know Dr. Universe and you know we need you to do 12 films and you have to play Dr. Universe did that ever
因为问题是 —— 首先 他们从来没给我打过电话 我简直不敢相信 真的 从来没有 我想总有一天他们会打的 他们会说 “有没有什么办法你能考虑扮演国防部长？一个站出来说 ‘请帮帮我们所有人 先生们 我们撑不下去了’ 的家伙” 我会成为那种家伙 我演不了朋克枪手 上帝 —— 上帝保佑你 因为你仍然在拍那种电影 —— 在绝大多数长片都被这些庞大的 —— 尽管其中有些很棒 不 我是说……
happen because here's the problem I first of all they've never called me once I can't believe that no no never and I think that if one of these days they will and they'll say is there any way you would consider playing the secretary of defense a guy who comes and says please help us all for men we can't we can't survive I'll be one of those guys I don't get to play the punk gun foods God God bless you because you still make the kinds of films you have continued in an era where where most features are you know the feature film market is dominated by these huge some of those are great no I'm saying
它们很棒 我有很多朋友拍这些 它们并不都那么棒 但有些确实挺棒 我说有些 我说有些 但有些挺不错 我 —— 我们都有我们崇拜的、超级有才华的朋友去拍那些 我不是那个意思 但似乎 —— 独立电影的市场在萎缩 因为它们是一个好故事 拥有出色的演员阵容 诸如此类 而你似乎就是其中之一 你处于一个非常独特的地位 你仍然在拍那些电影 我觉得这太棒了 我们惩罚 —— 我们惩罚了J·J·艾布拉姆斯 我们当时说 “去拍点喜剧吧 J·J……”
they're great and I have a lot of friends who do them and they're not all great but some of them are I said some I said some but some of them are okay are good and I we all have friends who we adore and who are super talented who make those I'm not saying that but there is it seems like a shrinking market for films that stand on their own because it's a great story and has a great cast and blah blah and you seem to be one of those people you're in a very unique position that you are still making those films which I think is awesome we chastised we chastised JJ Abrams we were like go and make some comedies JJ you
你知道的 我们一直在给他提要求 但你知道的 这是因为 汤姆 因为你 —— 汤姆 你就是我们的一员 并且你一直保持着作为我们的一员 尽管你变得如此出名、如此成功 持续了那么久 你依然保持着非常脚踏实地的状态 看起来很正常 我想这只是你从还是个小孩子时就保留下来的特质 你可能得感谢父母给了你这个 我想 我父母在我五岁时离婚了 这就是肖恩真正做功课的地方 他会知道的 汤姆 我不知道这个 —— 你的 —— 你的父母对你进入这个行业 —— 我称之为“树林” —— 有什么看法？
know we were given him wants to but you know it's because Tom because you cuz time you are us and you have maintained being us you as first famous and as successful of you as you have become for as long as you have been you have still stayed very grounded it seems and normal and I would imagine that that is just something you're stuck with from when you were a little kid and you probably got a couple of parents to thank for that I would imagine my parents divorced when I was five years old this is where Sean really does his research he would know that Tom I don't know this what are you what did your
你知道的 我在高中时开始为了好玩而演戏 因为我不敢相信你可以去演高中戏剧还能拿到学分 你知道的 这就是学校 我记得自己当时特别有这种想法 当我第一次走进戏剧课时 我这样做是因为我初中有几个朋友演过戏剧 我只是说 “我能来学校做这个吗？这太像是在瞎胡闹了 这太偷懒了” 我有完全相同的感受 我当时想 “天啊 每个人都在笑 这简直是……”
what did your folks think about you getting into the business tree as I call it you know I started doing it for fun in high school because I can't couldn't believe that you could go and do plays in high school and get credit for it you know this is school that's I remember specifically thinking that and first time I walked into a drama class and I did it because some friends of mine from junior high had been in the plays and I just said what I can come to school and do this this is screwing around this is goofing off I felt the exact same way I was like oh my god everybody's just laughing this is my
不仅是我 —— 还有我爸爸 —— 以及最终我妈妈 因为我们住在不同的地方 当我妈妈来看我演出之类的 他们只是 —— 他们只是觉得 “嗯 这真是太棒了 你看汤姆找到了什么” 肖恩 你谈到过你也有过 —— 你刚刚说过你有那种感觉 对吧？当时你想 “太棒了 这太有趣了 我简直不敢相信我能做这个” 在五、六、七、八岁时 —— 然后击中它 肖恩 嘿 现在 肖恩 当你 —— 你演过《承诺，承诺》（Promises, Promises） 谢谢大家 广场剧院 以前从未让人觉得奇怪 它是一部 —— 是一部大热作品 你对我说过 —— 因为……
both my my dad who and eventually my mom cuz we lived in different places when my mom came and saw me and stuff they just they just thought well this is just wonderful you know this is look what Tommy found Shawn you've talked about that you did you just said you had that same thing right where you were like yeah amazing this is so much fun and I can't believe I get to do this in five six seven eight and then hit it Shawn hey now Shawn when you did you did promises promises on thank you everybody plaza never brought it out weird and it was a and it was a big hit and you said something to me cuz
肖恩和我在社交场合经常见面 不仅仅是在这个播客上 所以在你演完《承诺，承诺》之后 它非常火爆 因为你在舞台上弹钢琴 做了所有这些事情 它是一部百老汇大热作品 几年前 我问你 “你还要再演吗？你还有渴望起来再演一部百老汇剧吗？” 你说了一句话 —— 我向你发誓 —— 我向上帝发誓 我听过作类似引用的唯一一个人 你们准备好了吗？我读过劳伦斯·奥利弗的一句名言 好了 你说 “我不确定我心里还有那把火” 是的 为了起来演八场……
Shawn and I see each other socially you know not just on this podcast so after you had done promises promises and it was huge because you played the piano on stage and you did all this stuff it was a big Broadway hit right a few a number of years ago and I said are you going to do it again do you have the desire to get up and do another Broadway show and you said something that was I I swear to I swear to God the only person I heard make the same sort of reference are you ready for this I read it as a quote from Lawrence Olivier okay you said I'm not sure I have the fire in the belly yes that's in order to get up and do eight
演出什么的 我记得当劳伦斯·奥利弗年纪大了的时候 总有人问他 “你还会不会回到国家剧院演出？” 他说 “不 因为这需要一颗更强大的心脏” 他说的不是医学意义上的心脏 他指的是投入到心中的那把火里的所有努力 好吧 肖恩 我们 —— 你会每周演八场 我记得你谈过 —— 你 —— 我们讨论了很多关于《承诺，承诺》的事 但你也说过同样的话 —— 你就像 —— 你做到了 你演了九个月还是一年？你演了多久？ 一年 一年 记得你说过类似的话……
performances or something and I remember when Lawrence Olivier was older and he was always asked well will you ever get up and at the National again what having he says it no because it requires a stronger heart and he wasn't talking about medically he was talking about all the effort that goes into the fire in the belly well Shawn we could you would do the eight shows a week I remember you talked what you've we've talked a lot about promises promises but you said some of the same you were like I do it you did it for nine months or a year how long did you do it for a year a year remember you saying you similar thing
你对汤姆说的话 你也说过同样的话 我问过你 “你会再演一次吗？” 你说 “我不知道我体内还有没有这个” 是的 五、六、七、八 然后 —— 不不 这是真的 汤姆 你知道的 —— 因为 —— 我把这个转达给你 —— 关于你必须在这些十年里从一部电影跳到另一部电影、另一部电影、另一部电影的持续工作伦理 它们全都很棒 并且 —— 并且正如杰森所说 你的作品总是 —— 总是那么棒 你总是全身心投入 你总是身处其中 —— 我把那个问题转回给你 关于拍电影 —— 你心里是否还有那把火 去旅行 5点钟起床 呆在这家酒店和那家酒店里 并且 —— 你说 “是的 因为这是 —— 这是我热爱做的事 并且 —— 是的 我会的” 没有任何其他方式来表达它 有 —— 有 —— 听着 这比好玩还要好玩 那是我很久以前学到的一件事 在我得到大湖莎士比亚戏剧节的工作之前 在剧院工作比好玩还要好玩 我当时想 “是的 这是一个 —— 度过你一天的绝佳方式” 这不仅仅是一种生活方式或 —— 你的人生工作 —— 这是一个 —— 人生 我太喜欢了 那么听着 在你的整个剧目库中 —— 是的 所有的演职员表中 —— 有没有哪一个 —— 你最喜欢的电影是什么 上帝啊 不……
that you said to Tom you said the same thing I said would you do it again and you said I don't know if I have it in me yeah five six seven eight and then no no it's true Tom you know because and I relayed that to you about about the constant work ethic you have to jump from movie to movie to movie to movie over these decades and and they're all great and their and and your work like Jason said it's always always fantastic you always committed you're always in it and and I switched that that question back to you about filmmaking is do you still have the fire in the belly to travel and get up at five and stay in
不不不 有没有哪一部电影或经历对你来说特别特别 永远留在你的脑海里 呢？你知道 我会说 听着 是的 它们在很多方面都是 —— 我听着 我拍电影从来没有过糟糕的时光 我离开一部电影时总是会说 “我简直不敢相信他们花钱让我做这个 太棒了” 尽管有种种不适和早上5点起床 —— 在65岁时可能稍微更难了一点 —— 但拍摄那部电影的经历 —— 那部 —— 《挡不住的奇迹》（That Thing You Do!） 我找了一群朋友来演 我们玩得很开心 那是我成立的公司的开端 太棒了 我爱……
this hotel and that hotel and and and you said yeah because it's what it's what I love to do and yeah I do yeah there's no other way of putting it there is there is look it's more fun than fun that was something that I learned a long time ago before I got my job at the Great Lake Shakespeare Fist work in the theater is more fun than fun and I thought yeah this is a this is a great way to to spend your day it's not just a lifestyle or you know life's work it's it's a life I love that and now listen out of all of the your entire repertoire yeah all of your credits is there one you what is your favorite movie Jesus no
那部电影 和加里·格茨曼以及 Playtone 的所有人在一起 我可以一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地做那个 那是 —— 那是你导演的第一部电影吗？那不是我第一次当导演 但那是第一部故事片 是的 里面有音乐 而且非常 —— 非常个人化 因为它设定在1964年 所以它是 —— 但你知道的 每一个演出都很宏伟 —— 那些可能 —— 稍微有点让人失望的 或者是那些你没有花足够时间去拍的 就像我刚刚 —— 我刚刚和韦斯·安德森在西班牙拍了两周的戏 和韦斯·安德森……
no no is there one movie or experience that was extra special to you that will always stick in your brain you know I will say look yes they all are in so many way I look I've never had a rotten time making a movie I've always come away from a movie saying I can't believe they pay me to do this that was that was fantastic despite the discomforts in the five in the morning a little harder at the age of 65 I guess but the the experience of making that the movie that thing you do I cast it with a bunch of friends we had a great time it was the beginning of the beginning of the company that I formed so great I love
剧团一起 那太棒了 我当时很沮丧 我说 “我们要走了 我们拍完了我的角色 我得 —— 我现在得走了 我想 —— 留连一会儿” 我刚和我们的老铁泰加·维迪提拍了几天戏 这简直是最棒的经历 然后 —— 然后就 —— 我们为HBO拍了一场秀 然后我刚拍了他的电影 我当时就想 “这些都是 —— 这就像是最棒、最好玩的一个月” 然后我就想 “噢 结束了” 是的 那是 —— 我只想去那个游戏里玩 —— 难道我们不能 —— 难道我们不能在某个地方拥有那种90天的经历 敲定一些东西……
that movie with Gary Getsman and everybody else down at Playtone I could do that again and again and again that was that the first film you directed that was the first not the first directing gig I had but it was the first feature film yeah and it was it had music in it and it was very it was very personal because it was set in 1964 so it was but you know every every gig is magnificent the the ones that don't that may be disappointed a little bit or the ones where you don't get to spend enough time doing it like I was just I just did two weeks with Wes Anderson in Spain with the Wes Anderson
然后起床 —— 好吧 你们给我们的不是90天 而是整整一个小时你们非常非常宝贵的世 —— 是的 非常感谢 谢谢你 —— 代表 —— 这两位聪明伶俐的聪明人 还有美国和全世界的每一个人 感谢你们为我们提供了所有这些你们创造的小世界 让我们所有人都能在其中生活 并且它们都曾在 —— 一个针对老二或老三的播客奖项中 —— 你、杰森和我将为那个奖项决一雌雄 你不得不问诸如“你最喜欢的电影是什么”之类的问题 你对此有垄断权 我会说在加拿大 这一直被称为《威尔·阿奈特的聪明人》 真的 真的 等等 为什么是第一名……
Repertory Company and that was fantastic and I was bummed out I said oh we got to leave we we've shot out my role I gotta I gotta go now I'd like to like to linger for a little bit I just got to do a couple days with our buddy Tyka Waititi and it was just the greatest experience and then it was just we did a show for HBO and then I just did his movie and I was like these were the it was like the greatest most fun month and then I'm like oh and it's over yeah and that was I just want to go and play with that game can't don't we don't we get to have that 90-day experience here somewhere you know pounding something
加拿大的播客 我想我刚刚被投票选为加拿大最受欢迎的儿子 我不确定 但我把它说出来 以防任何人想抓住这个并开始让它成为一个梗 我很乐意 —— 好吧 和你们聊天真是一大乐事 你们也是 汤姆 我简直无法用言语表达我的感受 我是如此 —— 非常善良 非常善良的家伙 你们听着 祝你们在 —— 有这个奖项的名字了吗？是 iHeartRadio 或者是叫大动脉奖 我们要和谁竞争？这是一个很大的问题 这是一个好问题 也许会碰上《硬核历史》（Hardcore History） 祝你好运 很高兴见到你 谢谢你 汤姆……
out and getting up and well you've given us not 90 days but a solid hour of your very very valuable time yes thank you so much thank you on behalf of of these two fellow smartless folks as well as everyone in America and the world for providing us all these little worlds that you have created that we all get to live in and they've all been there a podcast award for second bananas or third bananas that you Jason and I will battle for that one you have to ask questions like what's your favorite movie you got a monopoly on that I would say that in Canada this is known as Will Arnett's smartless that's true it's true wait why number one
非常感谢 很高兴见到你们 希望 —— 像我们这样的人最后都会去那些地方闲逛 好吧 小心点 伙计们 好吧 老弟 再见 汤姆 我觉得他会 —— 我觉得他会成功的 那家伙很有魅力 杰森 让我这么说吧 你一直在抱怨好一阵子了 你一直在说 “太棒了 你们这些优秀的演员” 然后你刚刚决定 —— 你掏出了其中一张 —— 我现在称之为 —— 因为我不用这个词 —— 作为 —— 王牌卡 我现在要叫它王牌卡 他 —— 他 —— 他是个优质股 那个家伙 —— 真是个妙人 我的意思是 他就是 —— 他确实有那种特质 我一直试图想出一个办法来问他这个 却不让他像平时那样巧妙地谦虚地转移话题 我只是有点放弃了 因为我知道他就是 —— 他不会喜欢 —— 他就是我们的一员 他完全平易近人又真实 他 —— 他绝对是你想追随的领袖 但他看起来并不那么傲慢或自负 —— 我不知道 怎么回事 —— 你是指我们作为观众 —— 不是那样 —— 是的 就像 —— 他就是你想跟随的家伙 从来不会让人厌烦 你知道的 看着他 —— 或者我不知道 —— 一直都这么稳定 是的 我不觉得自己是个普通人 我很特别 是的 好吧 —— 我就像普通人的老板 你知道的 所以当我在那儿 当我看到汤姆走进来时 我就会想 和我的一个员工共度时光真是太棒了 我希望他能继续保持他现在的多产状态 我的意思是 他在做什么 —— 比如每年至少一部电影 同样 —— 同样这里 这就是我所说的他拍的电影 我喜欢他一直拍那些 —— 看起来好像没有多少其他人还在拍的电影 而且 —— 是的 他的新电影 —— 我们刚才聊过 —— 是什么 —— 《芬奇》是的 不不 不 是《芬奇》 —— 芬奇那只鸟 是的 《芬奇》在Apple上 它基本上是什么时候上映的
podcast in Canada I think I just got voted Canada's favorite son I'm not sure but I'm putting it out there in case anybody wants to latch on to that and start making that a thing I'm happy to well it's a delight talking to you guys you too Tom I just words don't express how I feel I'm such a very kind very kind guys and you listen good luck on the is there a name for this award yet it's the I heart radio or it might be called the aorta who we up against that would be a big question there that's a great question hardcore history maybe up against hardcore sure fingers crossed so great to see you thanks Tom
加拿大的播客，我想我刚刚被评为加拿大最受欢迎的儿子，我不太确定，但我先这么说出来，以防有人想借此炒作并把它变成一个热门话题。我很乐意，和你们聊天太高兴了。你们也是，汤姆，我简直无法用言语表达我的感受，你们真是太善良了，非常善良的人。祝你们好运，这个奖有什么名字吗？是iHeartRadio奖，或者可能叫主动脉奖？我们的竞争对手是谁，这倒是个大问题，真是个好问题，《Hardcore History》也许是竞争对手，说不定呢，交叉手指祝我们好运。很高兴见到你，谢谢汤姆。
very much good to see you guys hope that well we'll hang at all those places that people like us end up at sure all right take care guys all right buddy bye bye Tom I think he's gonna I think he's gonna make it that guy's got some charisma Jason let me just say this you've been complaining for a couple you've been saying man great cast you guys and then you just decided you pulled out at one of these what I now refer to is because I don't use this word you as the the topper card I'm gonna now call it the topper card he's he's he's that he's he's a blue chip that one right now what a delight I mean he's just like he
非常感谢，很高兴见到你们，希望我们能在像我们这样的人最后都会去的那些地方聚聚。好的，保重，伙计们。好的，兄弟，拜拜。汤姆，我觉得他会……我觉得他会成功的，那家伙很有魅力。杰森，我得这么说，你抱怨了好一会儿，你一直在说，天哪，你们这群演员太棒了，然后你突然亮出了我如今称之为——因为我平时不用这个词——王牌，我现在要把它叫作王牌。他简直……他简直就是个蓝筹股，那家伙现在，太令人高兴了，我是说他简直
does have that thing and I kept trying to figure out a way to ask him this without him deflecting as he does so well so humbly I just kind of bailed on it because I knew he would just wouldn't like he's just got that he's he is us he is completely personable and authentic he is he's every bit a leader that you'd want him to be but he doesn't seem like he's too arrogant or cocky to like I don't know how does you mean us as a as an audience not that's three yes like he's just like he's the guy you want to follow and are never annoyed you know watching him or I don't know it's it's been so consistent yeah I don't see
确实有那种特质，我一直想找个方法问他这个问题，又不会像他平时那样谦逊地把话题巧妙岔开。我最后放弃了，因为我知道他不会……就像他就是我们其中一员，他完全平易近人又真实。他具备你所期望一个领袖该有的一切特质，但他看起来又不会太傲慢或自大，以至于……我不知道，你是说我们作为观众吗？不，就是……对，就像他就是那种你想追随的人，看着他时永远不会觉得厌烦，你知道的，或者我不知道，这种状态一直保持得这么稳定。对，我不觉得
myself as an everyman I'm special yeah well yeah I'm like the boss of the everyman you know so when I'm there when I see Tom come in I'm like it's great spending time with one of my employees I hope he keeps staying as prolific as he is I mean what he's doing like what at least a film here same same here that's what I meant about the movies he makes I love that he keeps making movies that are like it just seems like not a lot of other people are making and yeah his new movie which we talked on what is the the Finch yeah no no not the Finch just Finch Finch the bird yeah Finch it's on Apple and it's basically when is it on
我自己是个普通人，我很特别。对，没错，我简直就像普通人之王，你知道的。所以当我在那儿看到汤姆走进来时，我就觉得，和我的一个员工共度时光真是太棒了。我希望他能继续保持他现在的多产，我是说他做的事情，至少一年一部电影吧？我也是这么想的，这就是我说的他拍的那些电影，我喜欢他一直拍那些感觉别人好像都不怎么在拍的电影，是的，他的新电影我们刚才聊过，叫什么来着，是《芬奇》吗？不，不，不叫《芬奇》，就叫《芬奇》，那只鸟，是的，《芬奇》，在Apple平台上播映，它基本上是什么时候上映的？
Apple when is it it's not on now first week in November November 5th first week November 5th November 5th yeah so yeah so he's doing this movie Finch the sequel is gonna be the Finch I heard yeah no it's called Fincher it's called Fincher and David Fincher is directing it yeah are you kidding showbiz is incredible I know it's it's everything is aligned but it's about it's him and a dog and a robot and this is not the start of a joke but like could anybody pull off a high wire act like that but they do walk into a bar there is one bar walking to a bar the fair in fairness they walk but I saw the trailer to with
苹果什么时候上线？现在还没有，11月第一周，11月5日，11月第一周，11月5日，11月5日，对，所以他要拍这部电影《芬奇》，续集要叫《芬奇》，我听说，对，不，它叫《芬奇》，大卫·芬奇导演，对，你开玩笑吧，娱乐圈太神奇了，我知道，一切都安排好了，但讲的是他和一只狗和一个机器人，这可不是个笑话的开场，但谁能完成那样高难度的工作呢？不过他们确实走进了一家酒吧，确实有一家酒吧，公平地说，他们走进去，但我看到了预告片，和
my almost 13 year old and we watched it and looked at each other like yeah absolutely yeah and don't you feel like he's kind of like our ambassador not just for the business and not just for Hollywood not just for Los Angeles but like America too like quintessentially American and like he's one of the few people we can all both sides if you will can agree on yeah yeah yeah wait what's the other side I just met like both like never mind everybody in America can agree oh yeah Lachan we are not political sorry please what are you trying to do you try to lose your award you try to wade me into deep water and then
我快13岁的孩子一起看的，我们看完互相看了一眼，心想，绝对是的，难道你不觉得他有点像我们的形象大使吗？不仅代表演艺界，不仅代表好莱坞，不仅代表洛杉矶，还代表美国，就像典型的美国人一样，他是我们少数几个双方（如果你愿意这么说）都能达成一致的人之一，对，等等，另一半是指什么？我只是指两边，算了吧，全美国人都能达成一致，哦，对，拉坎，我们不谈政治，抱歉，你想干什么？你想失去你的奖项吗？你想把我拉进水深火热之中，然后
you're gonna take me down like a crocodile and keep me under bye you can't fucking bail out like that you can't roll yourself out yeah you can't be saved by your own bell we've used every word that you could do with buy no not at all no but also you were just trying to bail yourself out of a sinking ship and you can't you can't use buy as as a as a some kind of you know instrument to bail out your sinking ship why not I just did yeah I guess I can sorry there is no rule in that you're right you can but do you think that when he first moved one of the questions I did get to here was what he was 1979 he
像鳄鱼一样把我拖下去，把我按在水底，再见，你不能就这么他妈的溜走，你不能自己滚蛋，对，你不能靠自己的钟声获救，我们已经用尽了你能用再见说的一切，不，完全不是，不，而且你刚才只是想从一艘下沉的船里逃生，而你不能，你不能把再见当作某种工具来从下沉的船里逃生，为什么不能？我刚刚做了，对，我想我可以，抱歉，没有那样的规则，你是对的，你可以，但你觉得他刚搬家时，我听到的问题之一是，1979年他
made a move to New York City and he was trying to be an actor full-time so I wonder if he was just trying to take a bite smart list is 100% organic and artisan Lee handcrafted by Bennett barbecue Michael Grant Terry and Rob on Jeff smart loss our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
搬到了纽约市，并试图成为一名全职演员，所以我纳闷他当时是不是只是想咬上一口。《智能清单》是100%有机且纯手工制作的，由Bennett, Barbecue, Michael Grant Terry和Rob on Jeff制作。《智能清单》下一期节目将在两周后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过在Apple Podcasts或Wondery App上订阅Wondery Plus来提前收听且无广告。本期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。